جدل يعود للواجهه بعد تقارير قالت ان
وكاله الطاقه الذريه اكتشفت ماده يورانيوم
مخصب بدرجه نقاء تبلغ نحو 84% في احد
المواقع الايرانيه فما الذي يعنيه ذلك
الاتفاق النووي كان ينص على ان تخصب ايران
اليورانيوم بنسبه لا تتجاوز ثلاثه وسته
اعشار في المئه لاحقا وفي ظل التعليق
الاتفاق الذي انسحبت منه واشنطن خلال فتره
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب اعلن استهران
زياده نسبه التخصيب الى نحو 60% نسبه
84% اضحت قريبه جدا من تحقيق ما يعرف
بالعتبه النوويه اي ان الوصول الى
يورانيوم مخصب بالنسبه نقاء يربح بين 90
وخمسه وتسعين في المئه يفسح المجال امام
صناعه قنبله النوويه يضاف الى ما سبق شرط
ضروري وهو كميه اليورانيوم حيث تتطلب
قنبله واحده نحو 25 كيلوجراما من هذا
اليورانيوم
[موسيقى]